start doing it last very last session I
guess of the workshop today I'm going to
tell you a little bit about us faster
algorithms for some marginal
minimization in the setting where we
have a little bit more structure on the
function and this is based on your own
work we win one from Northeastern
University and lots of egg from London
School of Economics and both Hui and
lots ER here at at the semester ISO so
the money focus on the stock will be on
some modular minimization so we have a
set function upon a final graph set
which is some modular and we want to
minimize it so we want to find a set of
minimum value all right so this is a
it's a fairly general problem it
captures classical problems which says
the minimum is d cut problem in graphs
it also arises in some nice applications
for example arises in image segmentation
in computer vision or more generally
imprints in probabilistic models it also
arises in a completely different type of
applications such as structure sparsity
and this is a very well studied problem
with a very long history and I cannot
hope to do it justice here for those of
you who went to to the bootcamp you
probably see so much more about so much
of minimization a step on his talk
so I briefly highlight some some key
points perhaps one of the most important
ones is that this problem is actually
solvable in polynomial time it's one of
the most general discrete optimization
problems for which we we know how to
solve an important on your time and we
have different ways to do this too so we
have community organs based on maximum
flow ideas we also have algorithms that
are based on the ellipsoid and cutting
planes so perhaps one potential downside
of all of these methods is that the
running time is usually fairly high
still so it's at least n to the cube e
is the ground set of the function so
it's a set of elements of size n I so so
in the stock so whereas all of these
algorithms
that I mentioned here and they were the
work in general and they only assumed
black box access to the function so so
so we're given a valuation oral call so
if we want to find the value of this
over said we just create the Oracle but
for those of you who went to the
bootcamp hablas an excellent question at
the end of Stephanie's talk rather if we
turn in a slightly less black box our
setting and we know a little bit more
about our function can we do better and
this is precisely the viewpoint we'll
take you here so here we're going to
look at some special cases of this
problem where we know more about the
structure and we hope to leverage it to
get faster algorithms so specifically
what kind of structure are we going to
look at so so here we're going to look
at what we call the sum of some modular
or also decomposable setting so the idea
is that our function is actually a sum
of other functions Fi
so we have a bunch of these functions
and what's nice about these functions
they find is that they're much simpler
so what do we mean by that so so formal
definition is that we have a first
subroutine for minimizing the function
and maybe with the addition of a linear
function so we can minimize fi plus some
linear function on the same ground set
we'll see a different way to look at
this later on but the point is that each
of these functions are is simple and
we're adding them up and we want to
minimize the sound
so what is an example of that so very
simple example actually arises in in
graphs so see if you look at the minimum
SD card in the cut function of a graph
so what is that right so so for every
set of vertices like this one the the
cut value is the total number of edges
leaving so that's called the cut
function and this naturally decomposes
along the individual edges of the graph
so so we can think of the the cut value
as sum over the individual edges and
this is simply saying is the stage
leaving the set or not so is the cut
function of a graph with a single edge
so so so why is this helpful
well because each of these edges is much
simpler right so if we have a graph with
a single edge finding the minimum cut is
trivial but if we look at the big graph
with a lot of edges find then the
minimum cut is much more difficult so
simple local structure leads to more
complicated global structure but
nevertheless we can hope to leverage the
underlying decomposable nature of the
problem so that is one example but one
advantage of the this model is that it's
not just a cut function that has this
structure it's so so it also captures
other settings we might be interested in
so for example we could have a hyper
graph and we can decompose the cut
function of the hyper graph into the
individual hyper edges or a completely
different kind of setting would be when
each of the functions in the
decomposition is local in the sense that
is defined only on a small subset of the
ground set so all of these are
decomposable in our set so good so
that's the main focus of this talk how
do we do some other minimization in the
studying where we have the sum of
similar structure so so I'll show you
two types of albers it's both of which
leverage the structure to do faster than
done in general so the first class of
algorithms are based on gradient descent
and the second class of algorithms are
purely combinatorial and
based on maximum flow algorithms from
from graphs and hopefully at the end
I'll connect those two things together
and show that there's actually a nice
connection between that just depends on
different subsets so they're not
necessarily determine yeah so they could
be overlapping yes so so you mean that
they're disjoint so they they could be
overlapping this picture is misleading
so it's okay if they overlap so that's
that's actually also they interact so so
they do overlap okay so that is the plan
for today so before we get to any
algorithms actually I want to briefly
mention so the main combinatorial
concept that we'll use in all of these
algorithms is that of a base polytope of
Samarra function so i want to briefly
mention the the definition in case you
haven't seen it but if you forget it
it's okay so the base polytope it's a
very important poly tope associated with
semaj functions and it's a set of points
in n dimensions where n is the size of V
the ground set and you can think of a
point in n dimensions as a linear
function over the ground set so it's
assigned some weight to every element
and such a linear function such a weight
vector it belongs to the base Polito
if I satisfies the following constraints
so if you look at any set us the total
weight there are signs to us it should
be no more than half of us and moreover
they should be tied at V so the total
weight at assigns to V should be exactly
equal to F of V so so this is a set of
points in n-dimensional it turns out to
be a polytope and has some really nice
properties no so now we can just dive in
so the first class of volumes that
auction are you are based on gradient
descent so
where where does this come from so so
you've been to Stephanie's talk you
might remember that there's a very
intimate connection between Samara
minimization and convex optimization so
in particular we could write a convex
formulation for the discrete problem
which is minimize a semaj function that
is exact and there's all different ways
to do this the one that I'll use here is
this the following so so instead of
solving this discrete problem we can
think about solving this convex
minimization problem where what we want
to find is the point Y in the base
polytope that has minimum norm squared
so this is l2 norm throughout the talk
l2 norm so so this is the point why we
minimum norm squared in the base pollito
so if I if I solve this convex
optimization problem recovering the
optimal solution here in the discrete
setting is very easy all I have to do is
stretch out this vector as zero so I can
just look at all of the entries of Y
there are and more zero and that will be
my optimal side so so from now on we can
just focus on solving this convex
problem how fast can we solve it right
so just like we have any convex
minimization problem how fast we can
solve it depends on two things what is
our objective and what is our constraint
so so our objective is the norm squared
of a vector in n dimensions so that's
very nice it's a quadratic it's one of
the nicest Converse objectives and our
constraint says that we need to be in
the base polytope of the sub-module
function and that's what makes this
problem complicated because this
constraint is fairly complicated and
this is a combinatorial objects a
polytope described by exponential many
inequalities so so this constraint is
potentially very complicated and our
somato minimization problem turns out to
be quadratic optimization over this
volatile
so but luckily for us there's one
optimization that we can do over the
base Polito very easily and that is
linear optimization so so there is a
very simple greedy algorithm that allows
us to optimize linear functions over the
base pollito and we can use this as a
starting point to get algorithms for
this optimization problem so for example
I said since we can do linear
optimization we can do separation so we
can use ellipsoid or cutting plane
methods to solve this problem so one
nice thing about these approaches is
that who will get provable polynomial
running times both weakly polynomial is
strongly polynomial one potential
downside is that this running time is
usually quite high also another approach
that we might want to take is to go with
iterative method so for example we could
use an algorithm such as Frank wolf and
there's also another algorithm which is
more practical which is called the
frigidaire wall and these these oscar
versions are very simple they they use
the linear optimization over the base
pollito and they're suitable for some
applications is the main downside is
that the the polling the the running
times are not polynomial they're pseudo
polynomial they depend on the maximum
function value and they're known to
require a large number of iterations in
some settings
but how about the decomposable sorry can
we do better
and the first takeaway message that I
want to convey is that in the
decomposable setting we can actually
leverage more of the convex optimization
tool kit and that hinges on a very nice
property that we have in the
decomposable setting so so it turns out
it's a very remarkable fact that if our
function is actually a sum then we can
we can represent the base polytop of
that function as a Minkowski sum of the
base polytopes of each of the function f
high in the decomposition so so point
here is the sum of points in here so
this is a fairly remarkable fact it's
not true in general it's true for some
modular functions so what can we do with
this so we can use it to rewrite our
convex formulation so if we know that
the function is additionally
decomposable so so we can think of our
convex optimization problem from this
viewpoint so we want to find a point
here data has minimum norm that point
has a decomposition into a sum in these
base polytopes so we can think about
finding these points in the
decomposition so we want to find y I in
the base polytope of Fi and subject to
that we want to minimize the norm square
of the sum so I'm just using this very
convenient fact why am I doing this well
so one nice thing happened here namely
that what was previously a complicated
constraint and now it decomposes into
these separate constraints over these
base polytopes of these functions Fi and
each of these functions is much simpler
than the original one so that the the
the constraint is nice is nicer and it
was other we also lost a little bit in
the objective and we'll see that later
but at least we managed to simple
constraining much more and it turns out
that the fact that each of these
functions are very simple gives us quite
a bit of flexibility because one of the
things that it implies is that we can do
quadratic minimization over the base
polytopes of these advice and that will
turn out to be very useful to us so so
so so just to summarize so by leveraging
this decomposable structure we can write
this convex formulation for the problem
which for which the country is
decomposed and it turns out that this
this kind of formulation can be solved
much faster using gradient descent and
it has been a nice line of work that
showed that we can get very fast and
practical algorithms using gradient
descent to solve this convex
optimization problem so the fastest
search algorithm so the fastest
shelburne comes from our work with
Quinlan and what we propose to do is
very simple so we so we propose to
minimize this convex objective using a
random block code in a gradient descent
so so you'll see in a moment what that
is if you've been to Marc talk you
already know what it is and there's also
an accelerated version of those and this
is this achieves the fastest running
times we currently have for this ok so
what is this algorithm so it's very
simple it's simply it's applying block
coordinate descent to this formulation
so here we think of each why I as a
block so that is our block so so the
algorithm starts with some initial point
that is feasible so each of the blocks
is in the appropriate base pollito and
in every iteration it will pick one of
these wise uniformly at random and you
will update them by solving a quadratic
minimization over the base polytope of
FI
so if you used to come to gradient
descent you'll immediately recognize
what this is if you haven't seen this
before here's one way you can think
about it so so why why are we doing this
optimization so it's really what we're
doing is that we are exploiting
smoothness in our objective
so in particular in every block the
gradient is Lipschutz so the gradient is
smooth in every block
so by just simply by integrating this
this property what we get is a very nice
facts that are potentially more
complicated objective function has a
quadratic upper bound it's a global
upper bound that happens to be tight at
the Curie point so one idea you might
have is that in order to improve your
solution we might think about minimizing
this quadratic so this is the quadratic
so we might think about minimizing it to
get a new point Y Prime
and we're guaranteed to improve because
this is a global upper bound and this is
exactly what we were doing here this is
a very standard gradient descent idea
so so genius this sum the norm squared
of this song and when you write graduate
high what does that mean for for
d---eight block so it's the the ice
block of the gradient so but that
usually does have more than one variable
yes so here we actually the blocks are
and dimensional so in this particular
setting yes we the blocks are
international so where is the magic
coming from so how come we could not do
this in general so it comes from the
fact that the only reason we could
actually perform this update at all was
that we assumed that each of these
functions is simple I said that allows
us to to do quadratic minimization over
those base polytopes and we can also
accelerate this and get a even pass an
algorithm but I will not talk about this
here so
so he stays in my feasible region
throughout because my feasible regions
says it would be couples so so my
constraint is that every block should be
in the appropriate base polytope and I
maintain this explicitly because I'm
doing a constrained minimization exactly
so that's exactly what we're leveraging
here so since this base polytopes are
simple we can do quadratic minimization
over them exactly thank you that's so
exactly that's what he was asking right
so the only so the algorithm lock rather
block or diamond gradient descent for
this formulation and we can implement
and but how fast does it run right how
did how quickly does it converge and it
turns out that we can actually show some
very nice guarantees for those so
specifically here's the running time
that we'll need in order to be be within
epsilon of the optimum value so so the
running time is n the size of the ground
set times R which is the number of
functions in the decomposition times a
log of the maximum function value over
Epsilon so this is how many quadratic
optimizations we'll do over these base a
little base polytopes
and one thing that I like to emphasize
here is that the dependency on the one
over epsilon is logarithmic and this
comes from the fact that we can actually
show linear convergence rate for this
algorithm and I'll mention right at the
outset that this is not immediate
because this objective is actually not
strongly convex so so it turns out that
for our specific problem we have convene
a Tory structure that we could leverage
and this is what I'll tell you at the
very end but the important here is that
we do get log of 1 over epsilon
converges and this is precisely what we
needed otherwise we would be running in
pseudo polynomial time
so for functions that are integer valued
we can even solve it exactly so epsilon
only needs to be about 1 over n so so we
get this kind of running time for exact
so this is all I wanted to say about
this algorithm for now and I'll come
back at the end and explain why we don't
have a strong convexity
and how can we use the combinatorial
structure to get around that but before
we go there let me give you a perhaps
completely different take on this
problem and different class of
algorithms which are combinatorial so so
the quest for computer algorithms for
some white or minimization goes a long
way back since the development of the
ellipsoid method who showed that some
ultra minimization is solvable in
polynomial time and at that point the
main focus became on whether we can
design communitary algorithms for the
problem and the reason being that the
ellipsoid algorithm was ultimately not
satisfactory so people expect that it
will not be very practical and also it
did not shed much light into the
combinatorial structure of the problem
and one of the key starting points of
this whole area was a very beautiful
framework which was introduced by
Cunningham and he designed a framework
for obtaining combinatorial algorithms
for some ultra minimization
so this eventually led to the first such
algorithm for general sfm and it is the
basic framework for all of the
combinatorial algorithms and in
particular will be the starting point of
the algorithms that I'll tell you in
this talk ok so what is this framework
so the idea is that we want to maintain
a point in the base polytope just like
we did before but instead of they
using gradient descent we want to use a
completely different kind of idea so
it's in particular we want to take
inspiration from algorithms for graphs
maximum flow algorithms and iteratively
update our point until it becomes
optimal so so there are several
questions that come to mind immediately
the first one is how do we even
represent a point in the baseball you
don't so in general the answer is well
it's a pollito we can always represent
it as a convex combination of vertices
and the main advantage of that is that
is very general so we can do this for
any similar function but there also
comes with a significant caveat so
maintaining a convex combination of
vertices of the base polytope turns out
to be very difficult to maintain and
update it's very expensive this is the
reason why all of the combinatorial
grounds for general isotherm are very
slow of course just like we did in the
continuous airing we could ask ourselves
but what if we have the composable
structure can we do better and it raised
out that yes we can and the reason is
very much the same reason we saw before
so the reason is that we can exploit
this remarkable fact and namely that we
can represent a point Y in the base
polytope of f as a sum of points y are
in the base polytopes of the individual
functions fi so this is a very different
kind of representation of a point in the
base polytope of F it's not a convex
combination of vertices and I turns out
to be much more versatile a way to
represent a point y well for the same
reasons as before so a lot of things are
a lot simpler when we're dealing with
these base polytopes of the simple
functions so we can taste membership in
the quadratic optimization
and so forth so this turns out to be
remarkably helpful so how do we exploit
it here so here we want to take a
different take and exploit this
decomposition so now let's think about
how we were updated so so let's say
that's that's how we're representing the
points but how do we update that so so
we're maintaining this point as a
decomposition into these points in the
base polytopes of FI how do we update it
and here this is where we we depart from
the continuous viewpoint so here we want
to put our the graph max look camp and
think about it very combinatorially so
so so the the very high-level idea is we
want to sort of pretend it is some sort
of a max flow instance so how do we do
that so what we do in max flow so we
have a current flow and we look at the
residual graph and we find some path and
augment along that path can we do that
here and the answer is yes so we can
define what we can think of as the
analog of the residual graph so so we'll
call this let's say auxiliary graph so
this auxiliary graph will be a graph on
the vertices will be the ground side and
we'll have arcs for these functions in
the decomposition and for every function
and every pair of vertices U and V you
will have an arc with some capacity
which is the exchange capacity between U
and V in the base polytope of FI what is
that
so it's a very simple idea so so let's
think about this point why I it's in the
base polytope of Si and we're looking at
U and V so let's imagine modifying this
vector in the following very simple way
so we decrease Y i of u by epsilon and
increase y i a V by Epsilon
the quiz one increase the other if if
the this new point that we get stays
within the base polytope of fi this is a
valid operation and the capacity is
precisely the maximum value by which
this is a valid operation okay so this
is called an exchange capacity so for
every pair of vertices UV and every
function I we have an arc with the
appropriate exchange capacities and
we'll treat this as a residual graph it
turns out that it's actually the
residual graph if the original instance
was a graphic our instance so at least
that checks out in the journal in the
same module setting it's a bleed more
complicated because these capacities are
actually correlated but nevertheless we
can think of it as a residual graph so
in particular we could think about
updating these wires by for example
picking augmenting paths in this
residual graph so pushing flow along an
arc precisely corresponds to this
exchange in the base pollito so what can
we do this so we could imagine running
algorithms and moons carbonates or pre
flow push so if we do this carefully it
turns out that this will actually work
ok so we can pretty much translate all
of the classical algorithms to the
Samarra setting so we simply use them in
this auxiliary graph and augment in the
same way that these algorithms would do
and the nice thing about it is that
really is faithful to the maximum flow
algorithm in the sense that the
elementary operations this capacity
computations are actually proportional
to the number of basic operations of
these original organs so for example in
preflop push that the number of push and
we label operations that we do is N
squared M and this is precisely what
this algorithm will recover in this
modular setting so the number of Oracle
calls will be N squared R because R is
them in that case so this is a very high
level but the basic message is that we
can pretty much translate all of the
classical algorithms with quite a bit of
care so so this is all I wanted to say
about these discrete algorithms so so
there are two two main points that I
like to make so to bringing everything
together so so one of them is that we
can actually use these discrete
algorithms to analyze the continuous
algorithms so there's a nice connection
between those two and and I'll show you
a little bit of that in the rest of the
talk you might also be curious to see
how these are two very different
approaches compare so so in because I
won't have time actually not going to
talk about this but you can take a look
at our paper which is also in the
archive so that we did an experimental
comparison of these different algorithms
on computer vision tasks and you can
take a look if you're interested in
seeing how how they perform so so one
takeaway message that is that in in
different regions some some the
continuous algorithms work better and
some odd regimes the discrete algorithms
work better as you might have expected
but in the remainder of the talk I'll
focus on this part where we we go back
to the these gradients and algorithms we
saw at the very beginning and we we try
to analyze them and the way we'll do it
is via these insights from the discrete
outlines some very interesting
all right so going back to the original
problem so it's the the problem that we
saw via gradient descent at the very
beginning of the talk was this this
problem in this convex minimization
problem where we wanted to find these
points Y I in the base polytopes of a
file that minimizes the norm square of
the sum so we have this feasible region
here which nicely decouples along the
individual functions Fi and we have
optimal solutions here and we want to
find one of these optimal solutions and
the way we saw are to minimize this was
using Brandon block coordinate the same
so so I said that at that point I
mentioned that we can show linear
convergence rate for for this this
algorithm and this is not immediate
because this objective function is
actually not strongly convex so so
because it is because of the sum inside
so for example you can easily see this
that the optimum is not actually unique
so we can move mass around between the
points Y I without actually changing the
objective so we have multiple optima so
the objective is not a strongly convex
so so instead of using strong convexity
you will show linear convergence in a
very different way which will be very
convenient dorium and this is what I
want to show you and in the next few
minutes okay so good so before we go
there so let us remind ourselves what is
strong convexity so so if we have a
function f that we're trying to minimize
over some feasible side what does it
mean for the function to be strongly
convex so what it means is that for any
two points like this blue and red points
the difference in function value should
satisfy this property so we have a term
depending on the grade
in a tram that depends on the distance
between those two points and here the
distance is l 2-norm distance so how is
this really useful to us well it's
useful in the following sense so when we
Enola is a gradient descent the way you
use it is in the following form so we
use it when the red point is actually
not some arbitrary point but rather is
an optimal point and what it tells us is
that if the the current blue point is
far away from from an optimum point in
distance then it's actually far away in
function value as well so this is the
this is the main property that we need
in order to translate in the Sun inside
possibly defending the one the right
hand side they're the same the function
value is the same at all of the optimum
points so you can make it be the same so
this is the closest optimal point so
there are many optimal points here and
this is the closest in business to the
blue point on the left hand side is also
closest it doesn't matter on the here
because the function value at all of the
optimum points is the same hand side
isn't necessarily the same as the right
hand side you can think of it as being
the same
all right so I said this is what we
really need so it's so let's let's just
give it a name so that we can more
easily refer to it so so I'll say that
our objective is a restrictive strongly
compacts with some parameter M you know
if precisely that property holds that
the difference in function value between
so the the function value at the blue
point which is a component and the
optimum function value is at least mu
times the the dis squared between the
blue point and it's closest afternoon
point so so it turns out that in this in
in this specific problem that we have
here we can show that the objective
function is strongly convex in this
restricted sense
we're a strong convexity parameter that
is essentially one over N squared okay
so this will come from the combinatorial
structure and once we have such a thing
it's a relatively straightforward to
carry out to be the usual analysis of
gradient descent to get the usual linear
convergence right so this is the the
heart of the matter how do you ensure
such a such a strong convexity parameter
points where here you're only looking at
the minimum this is to the minimum yes
exactly so it's so restrictive a strong
convexity only cares about an arbitrary
blue pole and and and the optimum side
as opposed to any pair of points and
this is exactly what we need to analyze
gradient design and this this is the the
strong convexity parameter that we can
actually lower bound so and so we can
show that this is at least 1 over N
squared so how does this work so so I'll
try to give you some the vague picture
and connect it to maximum flows and
hopefully that that will give you some
idea of where this is coming from so
right so just to remind ourselves so we
want to show that the difference in
function value is at least 1 over N
squared times the distance squared
between the Blue Point and is closest
optimal point
so how do we understand this well so
what is the the function value at the at
the blue point so the Blue Point has
blocks for corresponding to this base
polytopes
so it's a sequence of blocks and its
function value is the norm squared of
the sum of the blocks so if we sum up
the blocks we'll get this blue circle
which actually belongs to the base
polytope and the function value of the
blue point is the norm of that blue
circle by definition and in the picture
of the right we also have the minimum
norm point which is unique and the
optimal points here when we sum of the
block maps to that point as well so this
function value is the norm of this blue
of this red circle okay so the
difference in function value is the
difference is in the norms of these two
which is at least the distance squared
between them so because this is the L 2
norm L 2 norm is strongly convex so so
at least we're able to relate the
difference in function value to the
distance on the picture on the right but
that's not exactly what we wanted so we
want to relate it to the the other
picture on the left and the distances
between those points so really what we
want is to actually go back as well
so we want to go from the picture on the
right back to the picture on the last
and in particular what we're hoping for
is that we can take this minimum norm
here and map it back and decomposer into
an optic point on the left and without
increasing the distances too much right
so so we want the distance here to be
proportional to the distance here
proportional up to 1 over N squared
so why would such a thing be true and
how we will go about finding such a
decomposition and here it's actually
useful to think about what would we do
if we actually were in a very familiar
setting which is graph maximum flows and
cuts so so if this was actually a graph
instance and minimum cut expense what
would happen right so what are these
pictures so so it turns out that the
picture of the love corresponds to flows
so each function fi is a corresponds to
a single edge in the graph so a point
like the blue point here is actually a
flow it's an assignment of flow values
two arcs that does not necessarily
satisfy conservation so it's a pre flow
so here we have flows on the picture on
the left on the picture on the right we
have net flows at vertices so so here
the blue circle at every vertex is the
net flow of the the blue point
so it's outgoing flow - incoming flow
and you can also think of this as
demands so going back really is saying
I'm giving you some some net flows at
vertices I tell you that they should be
minus one units of flow at this vertex
and plus two units of fluid at vertex
and so on and we want to go from that
into an actual flow on the arcs that
that preserves distances in some sense
so if I give you net flows and you want
to produce a flow how would you do it so
so natural idea is to simply do a flow
decomposition so you can think of these
are net flows as demand so I want to
rather certain demands in the on on the
arcs so so so we can start with the zero
flow look at the residual graph find an
augmenting path between someone with
positive demand to someone with negative
demand and route along
so if you do this then we'll get a flow
corresponding to these demands or net
flows net flow add vertices and it turns
after that this is this decomposition
will suffice so it does not shrink this
misses too much is there's not a large
distance is too much and the picture on
the left I so so so this how we did in
the graph setting how do we do it in
general and this is where the connection
to what I mentioned in the Cunningham
framework a few minutes ago comes in so
we can do precisely the same kind of
idea only that instead of the residual
graph we're going to work with your
gazillion graph just like we did for the
discrete elegance and that turns out to
to work as well good so so let me
conclude with a very simple example
showing where this n square comes from
so here's a very simple example showing
that this this is do shrink by a factor
of n squared when we go to the picture
on the right so it's very simple it's a
graph it's a path and we have these
stars attached at the end so the this
blue circle here you can think of it as
putting a demand of 1 over N on all of
these words this is a minus 1 over n
here and 0 everywhere else so we can
actually route this this demand so so
the minimum norm point solution is the
all 0 demands and we can see that the l2
squared of the demand is 1 over N
squared from each of these guys it's
times n because there are n of them but
at the same time if you look at the
picture on the left which talks about
flows so the optimum flow is putting one
unit of flow on all of these edges so it
has to square norm isn't so that's so
that's that's an example showing that
the gap can be as high as N squared and
that's it thanks so much for listening
[Applause]
so we've minimizing a quadratic over VF
pi is easy so why not just doing block
coordinate minimization rather than
block or the ingredients ice so so how
do you think take a block and minimize
over that given that ingredient so
that's what we do though that's that's
exactly what we do in the random block
coordinate descent so we pick a random
block and do quadratic minimization over
that block and updated it's exactly like
this random block word integrating the
Sun random block minimization take a
block and minimize their actual
objective function not the auxiliary one
that has great you know G ok so instead
of minimizing the the quadratic you want
to minimize the because it's quadratic
being blocked Newton that's that's an
interesting thought I don't think I
thought about it but it's definitely
interesting idea
[Applause]